الياس كرم في القدس اعود اليك يبدو ان
هناك معطيات جديده فيما يتعلق بهذا
الاستهداف اطلعنا عليها
نعم جلال هنالك هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
التي تاكد على لساني مصدر امريكي وهي اتت
به قبل قليل الذي يشير الى ان الجانب
الامريكي لم يكن مسؤولا ولم يكن طرفا في
هذه في هذا الهجوم الذي استهدف هذا
المستودع للاسلحه من الواضح تماما بان
اسرائيل ربما هي همم
المعني اكثر في توجيهي هذه الضربه تحديدا
همم موضوع الصواريخ البالستيه وال- همم
القياده همم يعني هذا هذا المستودع الذي
ينتج ويصنع الاسلحه الباستيه والصواريخ
البالستيه لانه جزء مهم في المشروع انه
الايراني وبدونه لا يمكن لايران ان توجه
الصواريخ النوويه او ان تصدر الصواريخ
النوويه بدون هذا المشروع لان هذا همم
البرنامج مشير هنا الى هنا همم
بما زالت يلتزم الصمت على الاقل على
المستويين السياسي والعسكري في التعاطي مع
هذا الموضوع تحديدا جلال على اعتبار ان اي
اعتراف رسبي او تباهى من جانب اسرائيل
بانها هي بالفعل منتصف وراء هذا الوجوب
سوف يجبر ربما اطرف الاخر يجبر طهران على
الرد مباشره على اسرائيل وتوجيه ضربه
مماثله لهاسه وكان ذلك مباشره من طهران او
من جبهات القتال اخرى وتحديدا من الجبهه
السوريه حيث يتمركز او تتركز من الاشياء
تابعه لايران هناك وتستهدفها اسرائيل بين
الحين والاخر اسرائيل
هي ليست الضربه الاولى بالفعل جلال التي
تستهدف هذه المنشاه تحديدا او منشات
مماثله همم في الماضي همم عده ضربات وجهت
الى مشاريع حيويه مرتبطه بالمشروع النووي
الايراني من بينها المراكز التي
تعمل بها اجهزه الطرد المركزي كانت هنالك
ضربات سبرانيه تعرضت لها مصلحه الكهرباء
الايرانيه وايضا الموانئ الايرانيه وكانت
تنسب دائما الى اسرائيل هذا فضلا عن
عمليات اغتيال عديده طالت العديد من
المسؤولين عن البرنامج النووي الايراني
والمسؤولين وعن ام مرتبطين في هذا
البرنامج لكن الان جلال تشاهد بان وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه واجنبيه هي التي تتناول
المعطيات الدقيقه لما جرى في اصفهان
بالامس ومن الواضح بان مسؤولين اسرائيليين
من خلف الكواليس هم يز وسائل الاعلام هذه
بادق التفاصيل وعليك ان تتوقع جلال غدا
مزيدا من التفاصيل الدقيقه التي سوف تحدد
المسار الذي استهدف هذه المنشاه العسكريه
الايرانيه بتفاصيل اباق الان التفاصيل
التي خرجت الى على الملا تتحدث عن مسيرات
استهدفت هذه المنشئه وتلميحات بان اسرائيل
هي التي استهدفتها لكن غدا وبعد غدا وفي
الايام القادمه سوف تتسرب مزيد من
المعلومات رويدا ودائما الجانب الاسرائيلي
هو المسؤول عن هذه التسريبات هي عمليه
محاوله لجسم النبض لاحتواء اي رد فعل من
الجانب الايراني هذا من الناحيه لكن من
ناحيه اخرى توجيه رساله واضحه لطهران بان
اسرائيل قادره على بلوغي اهداف في عمقي
همم ايران ودار بها وهمم ايضا بالتاكيد من
جانبيه اسرائيل على انها تملكه
قوه رد عن قويه في منع ايران في هذا
الصيام لكن الاهم من كل ذلك جلال هو ربما
التوقيت الذي تستهدف في هذه المنشاه
العسكريه همم اولا نشير الى ان المباحثات
ما بين الدول الكبرى وطهران وصلت الى طريق
همم مسدود الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسرائيل ايضا على قناعه بان هذه
المفاوضات لم تعد تجدي نفعا وربما لن يتم
التوصل الى اتفاق اسرائيل من ناحيتها من
الناحيه الامنيه والسياسيه تعتقد بانها
ارتكبت خطا صادقا عندما حدثت اداره الرئيس
دونالد ترامب على همم وقفه همم وقف
التعاون مع ايران فيما يتعلق بهذا همم
الاتفاق وهي الان تريد من الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه ان تبني خطه عسكريه
محكمه من اجل توجيه ضربه عسكريه الى طهران
في قادم الايام على اعتبار ان ايران في
السنتين
ربما تقدمت وخطط خطوات متقدم في مشروع انه
خير دليل جلال فقط في عجاله على هذه
النقطه تحديدا هو المناورات العسكريه
الكبيره التي شهدتها اسرائيل والصحراء
النقب في الاسبوع الماضي وهذه لاول مره
تعلن الاداره الامريكيه وتعلن اسرائيل من
ناحيه اخرى لان هذه الخطه وهذه المناورات
موجهه ضد طهران وموجهه صوب المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه وكان اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده ان تستعرضان القوه ان تستعرضان
العضلات وتقولان بانهما جاهزهتين للتعاون
والمشترك من اجل التوجيه ضربه عسكريه
للمنشات النوويه على الايرانيه راينا
العدد الكبير من الطائرات الحربيه
والمقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه والتي
الشامله ايضارات الامريكيه من طراز 2 التي
شاركت في هذه العمليات همم المشتركه بحضور
سته الاف جندي امريكي
تدرب خلال هذه المناورات على تزويد
الغواصات وهمم تحديدا بالوقود وهذا يعني
ان الغواصات الاسرائيليه ربما ستشترك في
قادم الايام في توجيه الضربات العسكريه
للمنشات النوويه كما قلت انت الياس المزيد
من التفاصيل بدات تتكشف مصدر الاسرائيلي
لموقع ولا يقول بان المبنى المستهدف في
اصفهان كان مصنع لتنفيذ انشطه تتعلق
بتطوير صواريخ متطوره و بان العمليه كانت
ناجحه وشيء فقط الى ان ايضا لجنه الامن
القومي والسياسه الخارجيه بالبرلمان
الايراني تبحث الهجوم الذي تعرضت له همم
تعرضت له المنشاه في اصفهان تمهيدا لاخذ ق